on book TVs afterwards at 9 p.m.
muslim-american federal agent amarelle
nori discusses his experiences fighting
domestic terrorism and at 10
Bruce Hoffman talks about the historical
evolution of terrorism around the world
and the rise of modern groups like Al
Qaeda and Isis we wrap up our primetime
programming at 11:00 p.m. Eastern with
Frances Klagsbrun who recalls the life
of Golda Meir Israel's fourth prime
minister that all happens tonight on
c-span two's book TV starting now Zack
and Kelly Weiner Smith authors of
soonish
good evening and welcome to the Strand
bookstore I'm on Nancy bass widen I'm
the owner of the Strand for a little bit
of history the Strand was founded in
1927 by my grandfather Benjamin bass and
it was founded in an area that was known
as book row that ran along 4th Avenue
from Astor Place to Union Square and at
its height it housed 48 bookstores it
ran from about the 1880s until about
1960 and in the 90 years since then all
but all of these stores have shudder
leaving strand to be passed down by my
father Fred and now to me always
hopefully kept in the bass family and so
thank you all for being supporters and
readers tonight very excited to welcome
the power couple composed of scientific
researcher dr. Kelly Reiner Schmidt
whose work with parasites has been
published in in numerous scientific
journals and award-winning cartoonist
Zak whiner Schmidt known for his daily
webcomic Saturday morning Breakfast Club
it's called cereal which is one the web
cartoonist Choice Award for outstanding
single panel comic multiple times this
dynamic duel has been working together
for years on their podcast the weekly
Weiner Schmidt and they discuss their
things all things nerdy the culmination
of which is that is this creative and
funny collection of comics that examined
10 up-and-coming fields of scientific
study including celestial elevators
meant to take humans directly to the
moon
no NASA trainee needed and I think
they've also been working on no
one-year-old baby which is with friends
now we're also thrilled to have c-span
book TV with us here tonight too
the event will be available in a few
weeks for you
share with your friends and families who
weren't able to make it so for the
format tonight they're gonna talk oh
then we're gonna open up the mic to any
of your questions and they'll stick
around in signed copies of their book so
and now without further ado please join
me in welcoming Kellie and that to the
Strand hello hey we're the Wiener Smiths
we're happy you're here thank you for
coming we wrote a book it's a good
audience the book is called soonish ten
emerging technologies that will improve
and/or ruin everything
and I'm Kelly Weiner Smith that one I
study parasites and that other one
that's this guy Zach Weiner Smith
Saturday morning breakfast cereal whoo
so when we were starting writing this
book we discovered that there was a
paper written in 2011 by a group of
undergrads at Hamilton College and the
paper was called our pundits blowing hot
air talking our Talking Heads blowing
hot air essentially they looked at the
predictive abilities of 26 different
pundits and their abilities ranged from
mostly right but also there were there a
lot that were mostly wrong and the
important thing to us was that they all
still had jobs so we were like we should
write a book where we predict future
tech because it doesn't matter if you
get it right or not we have job security
and that eventually we decided that
actually predicting future technology
like it wasn't it's not particularly
interesting how long the Weiner Smith's
think it's going to be before you have a
space elevator what's interesting is
what still needs to get figured out
before a space of elevator exists so we
wrote a book that tells you a bit of
background about the technology tells
you about the major problems that we
still need to overcome to make that
technology happen and then we talked
about how that technology could make
everything more awesome and also how it
could make everything really horrible
and maybe destroy us all so we tried to
be even-handed with all of the different
technology
so we're gonna talk to you today about
about one of the technologies or one of
the chapters cheap access to space and
then we're also going to talk about one
of our nota bene z' so as we were doing
research we discovered a lot of stuff
that was really weird and we just
couldn't keep it to ourselves so we
decided to share it in the nota bene z'
and we're not going to talk about this
one in particular you'll have to buy the
book to find out more about this one but
this is one of the amazing things that
we uncovered while we were doing
research for this book so here you go
I'm gonna do it your turn oh boy well
Wow how's that is that good level
alright so uh yeah so this is a chapter
that's on all sorts of ways you might
get to space a little more cheaply than
our current conventional rocket method
and so we explore a bunch of different
technologies it's a pretty long chapter
with like I think it six seven different
paradigms some already kind of happening
and some totally implausible
I wouldn't say totally implausible just
it's going to be tough but yeah so in
this I guess for this talk we're gonna
tell you about a few of them so I'm I
guess I'll advance the slide here yeah
thank you that's a rocket so I guess we
should first talk about reusable rockets
which is just starting to happen
so the idea whether you reusable rocket
is to make rocket travel a little more
like plane travel so the way we describe
it is imagine every time you wanted to
fly from New York to Los Angeles
you sort of flew over to Los Angeles
jumped out and then the plane exploded
in the Pacific Ocean it'd be really cool
but expensive right and that's
essentially what we do right now with
rockets and so a big part of why it cost
something like sixty million dollars to
put a relatively small payload into just
low-earth orbit is is because the way
Rockets work right now so one idea is if
you could get the most expensive part
the machine itself back then you would
save a lot of money the fuel is like a
negligible part of the cost it's like a
few hundred thousand so SpaceX yeah just
a couple hundred thousand
but you know yeah as these things go
that's not too bad but so SpaceX just
was kind of able to do this they landed
part of a rocket and you might ask how'd
you come up with part of a rocket well
if you don't know the way space travel
works is a rocket is actually like three
Rockets stacked on top of each other
each smaller than the last and the
reason you do that is once you've used
up a chunk you don't want to carry the
dead weight of the metal Hulk so what
you do is you drop it into the ocean
so what spacex was able to do is take
the first one of those the biggest one
the first stage and landed on a barge so
this is a good first step in this
direction I think Elon Musk said they
could get the price down 90% on space
launch and if you multiply that by like
an Elon Musk conversion factor you and
with a pretty reasonable number I think
their own spokespeople said 30 to 40
percent which is enormous so that's
what's happening right now and we talked
about some other technologies that we
were told about by the NASA advanced
innovative concepts group including
putting a rocket on like a giant spring
like a pogo stick to just get a little
bit of oomph to get things going but one
of the things that we thought was really
exciting was the idea of a space
elevator and so a space elevator is
essentially three parts it's a station
that we put somewhere in the ocean that
stays in place it's a gigantic cable and
then it's a counterweight and in this
case the counterweight is a big honkin
rock and and there's an elevator that
climbs it and you beam power to the
elevator and the elevator just kind of
slowly goes up the cable and the people
who are interested in this design
estimate that they could get stuff up
into space for about 250 dollars per
pound and that's amazing because right
now it costs about ten thousand dollars
per pound so like if you wanted to send
a big gulp up to space that's like what
twenty five thousand dollars or
something
so $250 a pound would be like amazing
savings so the main thing that they need
to still figure out is like this middle
part and that that middle part is like
kind of importance and so the problem
with the middle part is that it needs to
be really strong but it also can't weigh
a lot because it needs to be sixty-two
thousand
so if it weighs a lot the weight of this
cord is gonna yank it down so it needs
to be lightweight but really strong and
recently somewhat recently there was the
discovery of carbon nanotubes which is
just the configuration of carbon in a
tube it's like the width of a hair and
it's much less than a human hair it's
very small thank you it's good work team
yeah together we know all this
information anyway so people have
managed to get them to be about a foot
and a half long and you may have been
remembered you may remember that I said
it needed to be 62,000 miles long so we
have a long way to go but it looks like
it might be strong enough to do it but a
problem that is coming up and this is an
interest was an interesting part of
writing the book was that economics
might be the thing that makes this not
happen so like for terrestrial based
purposes for carbon nanotubes it turns
out you really only need about a foot
and a half of carbon nanotubes to do
just about anything we want to do with
these tubes on earth and so at first it
was like if you drew out the projections
it was looking like we were getting the
lengths of these tubes you know longer
and longer faster and faster and then
it's just kind of flattened out ever
since so we need like if you could be
the person who make carbon nanotubes
long enough to make a space elevator if
you can get that moving again if you can
think of some earth-based reason why we
need really long carbon tubes and we're
doing questions at the end but hold on
to it
so the other problem with this middle
part is that if you can get the carbon
nanotubes long enough turns out they're
really not very good if there's
lightning and so we were asking NASA's
advanced innovative concepts group well
like what do you do about lightning and
apparently there's a little area in the
Pacific Ocean that has never as far as
we can tell experienced a lightning
bolts and so the answer is to put it
there and hope
the past tells us all we need to know
about the future yeah I hope climate
never changes yeah that would be
embarrassing yeah
oh sorry sorry what's the next thing
oh other problems like like the death
from the skies problem yeah okay so yeah
one other problem which we were a little
surprised it seemed like a lot of the
scientists hadn't really considered too
much not all of them but is there's a
fundamental problem with bringing
anything back to earth from space or
even if you're just an any paradigm
where it's cheap to get to space like if
you drop a heavy thing from high up into
Earth's gravity well it's like dropping
a nuclear missile and it's arguably even
worse because right it's bad with it
with the nuclear warhead a nuclear
warhead mechanism is kind of a ticklish
thing it has to go off just right if you
want to react it properly otherwise
it'll just knock itself apart whereas if
you drop say a hunk of tungsten a very
dense metal that's the equivalent of a
nuclear explosion there's not really a
good way to deflect it if you find out
about it too late probably the solution
might be worse than the problem you'd
have to maybe use a nuclear weapon to
knock it over and at which point you're
maybe in a worse position so that's you
know bad and and the the the the deep
part of it is that's probably a
permanent quality of life in a cheap
spacefaring world like there's not a
good solution to that problem that's not
a political one and I don't know how
much faith you have in human politics
right this second but you know trusting
even if you have faith in say the
American government there you know there
are other governments who want would
want cheap access to space so the other
reason you might want your your base
station it's not there anymore
you might think that the base station in
the ocean is because you might want your
space elevator to be kind of
cosmopolitan like to have it be a
multinational project strictly for
political reasons because the first
nation that has a space elevators like
the greatest military advantage in the
history of ever it's like you can
conduct any war from the top of a
mountain on anyone else
the ultimate higher ground yeah
it literally we're literally so we don't
know the solution to that problem I
don't know if anybody does other than
some sort of political some serious
well enforced laws about what you're
allowed to do in space especially in
your earth so you know it might not be
that awesome to have cheap access to
space I thought you were gonna tell
everybody what happens when you cut the
cool oh yeah anyone have a guess what
happens when you cut the cable on a
space elevator hey Gary
didn't know you're coming yeah anybody
have a guest what happens right the
elevator flies up now of course you
could cut it's not there you could cut
it high and and the down part will fall
but the way to think about it is if you
had a sling with a rock on it you were
doing this and you snipped it you might
intuitively know no matter where you
snip it the rock goes off in a straight
line and that's essentially what happens
with a space elevator so it's actually
not it's sort of disappointingly not
that dangerous to cut okay it's bad for
the people in the elevator or cool I
don't know but now you have this
ultimate piece of space junk right so
you have any chord yeah any bit of the
chord and that's attached to the rocket
goes off like through our satellites and
yeah that's them out as it goes so
people aren't dying but we could lose
millions and millions - yeah yeah that's
true and and we did it is interesting
what happens you can look up people of
mom what happens to the cable if you cut
it high and the short version is that
kind of whiplash is due to a whole bunch
of different forces acting on it which
is actually probably fortuitous because
it means it burns up the cable as it
comes down but yeah actually we were I
was doing a talking Google say at all
about this and there's this little boy I
think I really disappointed when I was
like probably nothing bad happens okay
so some of the concerns for cheap access
to space so Zack talked about the idea
that you could like fling stuff down at
earth and you know destroy everyone
which would be pretty bad but also the
reusable rockets they use per ton of
propellant so if we can get the cost
down that means we're going to be
putting a lot more pollution in the air
and burning up a lot more propellant so
that's something we need to decide if
we're all ok with
but yeah the biggest problem is going to
be potentially destroying humanity and
whether or not you can trust people with
that in terms of how it could change the
world you want to tackle them sure I
mean in a sense it's obvious right so
you you know have cheap access to space
but what's kind of really neat about
that is a lot of the reasons that we
don't go to particular places in space
are just economic like the way I like to
say it is if you're a really sort of
mean-spirited economist when the Apollo
landing happened you might have been
like well this isn't sustainable you
know because I forget something like
four-and-a-half percent of the
discretionary budget that year or like
maybe in 67 like a couple years prior
was spent on NASA which was mostly the
Apollo program at the time it was
definitely not a return on investment
sort of thing would you drop the so the
estimates unit or you drop the price by
about 95 or more percent of going to
space it kind of changes everything it
means private citizens who are not that
rich or relatively small companies can
have well cheap access to space so that
might change how we feel about things
like lunar colonies or Martian colonies
which are obviously very expensive
endeavors yeah we could finally become a
spacefaring species if it's cheap to get
stuff up there you know like so if the
space elevator can be made to work for
example it's you know I mentioned
already is ten thousand dollars to get a
pound of stuff into space if the space
elevator works you just put all the
stuff to make your spaceship on the
space elevator you bring it up into
space you build the space at ship in
space and then you go explore the
universe
like we could suddenly become a
spacefaring species if we could get
stuff up there cheap which is just
mind-blowing and amazing to me to
imagine so
alright cheap access to space but let's
talk about robots killing humanity
because that was a little bit too dense
so okay so this is our programmable
matter section but we decided to talk
about space tonight instead all right so
here's one of our favorite nota bene s
from the book this is the nota bene on
how it will end for humanity these are
stories about robots interacting with
humans do you want to tell the story of
promo bots no yeah yeah okay this is
kind of a couple stories about weird
robot stuff so when we came across was
this Russian come to
promo but which I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing you are thank you yeah so
promo bot is this robots designed to
like recognize faces and it's point is
to assist humans especially the elderly
and so that's its job as it's designed
to like sort of think and read people's
emotional responses and it keeps trying
to escape it's escaped it's escaped I
think at least twice when I wrote the
book it was up to two for all we know
it's gotten away for sure now it's and
it's uh it's gone but yeah it's funny
story and and it's like the robot
escaped and it actually died on the road
it's it's it's kind of tragic but you
know not ideal of its job is caretaking
for humans if it's trying to run for its
life so that's the first robot story
okay so this next robot story is amazing
alright so Serena booth is an undergrad
at Harvard University and she decided
that she was interested in seeing how
much undergrads would trust a robot that
was asking for permission to enter the
dorms so there's at least three reasons
why undergrads should not be letting
robots into the dorms so one apparently
privacy is a huge issue I didn't know
this but I guess tourists are really
interested in getting photos of the
inside of Harvard dorms which seems
supremely creepy to me but is a thing
and so she said that she's had people
like stick cameras up to her window and
take photos of the inside of her dorms
so anyway privacy concerns are
apparently huge in this creepy world we
live in - there had been bomb threats
recently and so they had all gotten
emails being told to not let anybody
into the building and three there had
recently been a string of thefts lots of
reasons to not let people in but with
the undergrads think to not let robots
in was what she wanted to know so she
made this robot that she was able to
control by sitting at a table and she
would have it go up - in the first case
just one undergrad and say hey would you
let me in the building you know I don't
have the code can you let me in and 21%
of those undergrads said yes so it's
still a pretty low number maybe higher
than you'd like but low number if it
went up to groups
71% of them
of those groups said yes so any robots
out there take note humans are real
stupid in groups and the real trick to
getting this robot to let them in was
cookies so the robot came up with a box
from one of the fancy local cookie
stores and to be clear this box did not
actually contain fancy cookies it
contained snickerdoodle cookies from the
local grocery store and if you
approached individuals or groups with
the cookie BOTS you were real likely to
get led into that building and so I
think that the lesson here is that
humans would sell each other out for
snickerdoodle cookies from the grocery
store not even the good ones okay and
then the final story there was a guy
named paul robinett at Georgia Institute
of Technology and he wanted to know how
much humans would trust robots in an
emergency so he had these undergrads
they were told that they were gonna take
a survey they followed the robot into a
room where they were supposed to take
the survey and then the experimenters
released smoke into the room and turned
on a fire alarm and then the undergrads
had a choice they could either follow
the robot out to safety or leave the way
they came in so let's be clear they know
how to get out of this building and we
were told that almost all of them
decided to follow the robot after the
smoke alarm went off and that seemed
crazy to us but it seemed real nuts
after we watched the video because that
is a slow-moving robot it is it like
crawled its way out of there and they
knew how to get out and so then they
decided to up the ante so the next thing
that they did was they had the robot
first go into the wrong room and circle
the wrong room and then bring them to
the correct room and the undergrads
still followed the robot when the smoke
alarm went off and then the last thing
that they did seemed maybe a little bit
mean but they had the robot when the
smoke alarm went off take the undergrads
to a room where the lights were turned
off and the room was blocked by a couch
and the robot just stood there going
this way to get out and two of the
undergrads had to be retrieved because
they stayed there waiting for the robot
to do something else and and these are
not I do not think that these are stupid
undergrad
like Georgia Institute of Technology and
Harvard these are like some of our best
and brightest but I think the point is
we really trust robots and what's
interesting is that these robots in each
case did not look any better than trash
cans with like a red ribbon around them
so the robots don't even need to look
that good for us to trust them with our
lives so if you have if you're a robot
with a cookie you can pretty much do
whatever you want to American undergrads
and they're just gonna go with it
so that's that's an example of one of
the no debates from our book we thank
you for your time
and we would be happy to answer any
questions you have about the book and
technology and there if you raise your
hand there's a microphone that will come
to you so we had a question up here do
you still have the question okay
wait wait for the microphone to come up
to you sir when you mentioned carbon
nanotubes is this like that's the
filament and you want weave it together
into a thicker strand or it's really
just one nanotube yes the problem is I
can I heard out a little bit about this
so like there's this quantity called
specific strength and if you're like
more maithili inclined that's strengthen
the sense of how much force you can
thwack it with before it breaks divided
by density but simply put you want
something like Superman's hair right it
needs to like weigh very little be quite
strong and so carbon nanotubes kind of
just hit the spot and maybe having
enough of this quantity specific
strength which is already not ideal from
an engineering perspective but set that
aside
the moment you start weaving them you're
lowering your specific strength and
you're increasing the likelihood of a
specific breakpoint emerging and any
breakpoint is bad any breakpoint the
whole show is over so yeah you need to
have you're literally talking about a
100 thousand kilometer long molecule so
and moreover like I don't know if you
have a visual of what a carbon nanotube
is you can imagine a honeycomb shape of
carbon atoms and little hexagons and if
you're missing just one of those carbons
you've got a problem right so you see
how hairy the problem is it's not an
easy thing and and so that's why we say
probably the best way to go I mean that
sounds impossible but you know there are
lots of technologies that meet crazy
levels of quality it's just those
technologies all have markets for you
know small iterative improvements and
nobody needs you know ten feet of that
molecule they either can use little bits
for composite materials or 100,000
kilometres yeah so you can't leave it or
you can't but you lower that quantity
hey you guys ended up at ten how many
did you start with and how did you win
oh it down so we started with fifty uh
and then and then as we started writing
it became clear that we weren't gonna be
able to do any better than like us maybe
funny Wikipedia article on each one and
as nerds we felt like it would be more
satisfying to do a deeper dive so then
we started on 25 and we still that still
wasn't it and and by the time we
finished writing a couple chapters it
became clear that 10 was going to be
about the right number given how wordy
we are so we tried to find technologies
where they weren't so new that you
couldn't tell if it was just a bunch of
crackpots proposing something that would
never work out or so far along that the
only thing that was left to figure out
was details so we because that's a
little bit less interesting to talk
about
so we weeded those two things out and
then we tried to weed things out that we
thought economics wouldn't allow to work
and so actually the last chapter of our
book is a graveyard that talks about
some of the stuff that we spent like a
month researching and then at the end
we're like now this isn't gonna work so
quantum computing for example ended up
just being too complicated to do in a
way that we felt was accurate enough do
you want to speak to quantum computing I
don't I can't explain it
yes they're just certain constraints
right so we long this chapter in the
book is like 10,000 words and so we got
into quantum computing we actually wrote
I think about half or two-thirds of it
and it was already 20,000 words and that
was like no jokes just like one sentence
after another trying to get it across
and it was just we eventually just felt
like we had better do it properly or not
do it and so that's one that's in the
the graveyard there there are three more
chapters in it and that's not the only
stuff we dropped from the book but
that's the stuff that there was like a
sort of argument we wanted to talk about
yeah so we the stuff had to fit a
certain length and be explainable and
and be not be s those were our main
criteria they also had to be something
we were interested in getting about for
a month yeah mostly we picked like the
ten that we thought were fun but we're
different enough from one another it
wouldn't be too repetitive yeah
hi so it's actually an SMBC question in
your bonus panel you often allude to
Kelly disapproving of some of your jokes
so can you give some examples of comics
that have been vetoed by Kelly who tells
you she has veto power the one she
vetoes are my favorite ones to do so he
does do them anyway and the best example
of that is the unlubricated single-use
monocles i still don't get it but it was
but we got a nice check so single-use
monocles comm he sells them in 25 packs
I don't know how that happened some
people have busy lives anyway so it's
interesting actually so I've met people
who expect me to be super grumpy because
I look grumpy and those panels on his
comics but I'm not actually a grumpy
person and neither are children which he
has scowling all the time oh don't you
you're gonna get Oh far out do you like
are you scrambling the night before
every day every every comment comes out
or like do you have like a month's worth
of comics ready to go right this second
I have exactly enough to get us through
this book tour
so typically I'm not scrambling I try to
get a little bit ahead but it's not easy
with kids yeah so if I'm being good I
try to be 2 weeks ahead but that's
that's unusual
which of these technologies do you think
people could screw up the most or like
would be the worst situation the worst
for Humanity yeah I used to I I do think
it's the thing that Zach already talked
about like so if we can figure out so
cheap access to space is one way to get
to space more often but at we also
talked about asteroid mining and they're
a major important part of making that
happen is figuring out how to wrangle
asteroids and so essentially they're
capturing asteroids and then moving them
to some other place and having the
ability to fling an asteroid at earth is
petrifying given humanity's track record
do you have a different answer yeah I do
but I just wanted to add to that just to
give you some intuition and we talked
about this in the book from like open
space you can just go anywhere for
almost no energy which from a like
weapons standpoint is a little freaky
like the example we give is to fling
something from the surface of our moon
to earth takes more energy than flinging
something from one of the moons of Mars
to earth and the reason is the moons of
Mars Avira Singh then they look like
potatoes they don't even have enough
mass to hold themselves into a little
sphere right yeah so we calculated if
you get enough traction you could
actually fly off one of them in a
motorcycle which is so cool
but but so what I would I was what I was
gonna say I actually think we do each
have from what's called brain computer
interfaces which is what it sounds like
which for me is kind of the freakiest
technology for a couple reasons like one
you know it's like it it's full extent
you you probably make humans kind of
unrecognizable which is I don't know a
little upsetting and but also there's
this weird thing about brain computer
interfaces which is one
you're basically offloading the last
vestige of privacy which is you know
this go between your ears where you're
allowed to think whatever you want the
moment this is the ability to interface
you know that you're giving up that
little last spot and it's a little more
ominous than that because probably the
first person who gets one of these to
work to say juicing like boost your IQ
boost your memory etc has like an
economic advantage
that's rather severe so meaning there
you could get into the situation where
people kind of have to use it in fact
it's already happening a little bit and
academia I forget something like 20 25
percent of elite academics will admit to
using brain and
drugs so that you're already getting
this sort of market for brain alteration
and and if we have a really nice brain
computer interface system it's like
everyone has to use this device and it's
gonna change the way our brains work and
for me that's a little little freaky
does everyone understand what a brain
computer interfaces roughly okay yeah
it's a question behind you sort of just
a follow up to what you just said would
you argue that like current computers
and cell phones aren't changing how we
are and we don't have the same economic
forces to have those yeah that's that's
interesting I'm kind of skeptical about
how much difference this stuff makes to
like fundamental human processes you
know what I mean like um you know the
way I would say it is is is you could
take like a human being from say a
hundred thousand years ago and pop them
in the modern world as a baby and that
you wouldn't know the difference but a
brain computer interface person has like
literally different physical qualities
in their brain and I'm just talking
about the beginning like you know just
IQ boost memory boost the stuff we all
want I mean but if you iterate that over
I don't know 50 years you're talking
about technologies we can't even think
about you so maybe fundamentally
altering human brain processes in ways
that are much more foreign to us than
just having like you know a thousand
friends on Facebook like a weirdly large
casual acquaintance group you know so
yeah I do I do think it's different in
kind than that's our stuff well and if
you follow this technology out to the
extent that the researchers imagine it
we'll get to you get to the point where
all of our thoughts are shared with one
another so we were talking to Gerwin
shock and I asked him you know what is
the end where do you guys see brain
computer interfaces going eventually and
the answer I expected was like you know
quadriplegics will have the ability to
move any limb that we give them they'll
just have to think about it and the legs
will move their arms remove their
fingers will move but the answer he gave
me was well one day we're gonna be able
to like load all of our thoughts onto a
cloud and we're gonna share all of our
thoughts we're gonna be one big like
super organism
and and at first I was like I wonder how
many people think that and so then I
asked the other people that I
interviewed like is that something that
everyone talks about and they're like
yeah you know like for most interviews
we talked about the like prosthetics
thing but like yeah one day we could all
probably load our brains into one cloud
and we'll be one big organism and and I
kind of feel like that's horrible
because I like I think that both
marriages and society work because
that's not happening and and I feel well
anyway and so and and he but Gerwin who
I spoke with agreed so he said you know
but it could be bad like you could be
sitting there watching TV and think to
yourself I might want to divorce my wife
and she would know that instantaneously
and that might be bad yeah yeah and I
was like yeah that that might be bad but
he did but he made a good point that
like what what would that mean for
Humanity would be something different
than we've ever been before and so I
feel like if we ever get to that point
then we've definitely gone way beyond
you know what it's like to have privacy
concerns on Facebook and stuff like that
to something just totally we're totally
different kinds of humans at that point
so I guess we'll wait to see if that's
going to happen
so kind of related to what you said
about humans from a hundred years ago
being you know relatively similar do you
think that that is also true it's like
you talked about how trusting we are of
robots now do you think that that would
have been true if they had encountered
something that you know hundred years
ago is this a relatively recent
development
you mean like trust in technology and
technology like you talked about how
they trusted robots to guide them out of
rooms and such this is something that
we've developed since like you know
peoples were carrying smartphones around
trust me I I mean this is you know I
don't have good science on this I I
consider that our two forces you kind of
see it work if you look at old science
fiction there is a sort of general trust
in progress and we've sort of dispensed
with that that now seems naive on the
other hand we're more like in touch with
computers all the time
so I don't know like this is this joke
we tell but it's kind of in a weird way
of sort of serious which is if you look
at a movie like terminator it's it's in
a way really flattering to humans
because it's like wow in order to kill
us they have to have like a time machine
and this like fancy exoskeleton they
make like skin on the face so it looks
real it turns out like a trash can with
cookies is this is all you need so but
it's not only that will fall for but we
conceive of ourselves maybe as being
less trusting than we are in the moment
so but in terms of like the
historiography of it I don't know I my
guess would be it's funny because I just
reading some economic stuff on how in
the US were much less trusting of each
other than we were 50 years ago so I
don't know if that means we're more or
less trusting of robots like doing like
robots better because we hate each other
I don't know yeah sorry I don't have
like a definitive answer that's an
interesting question though which
emerging technology or concept do you
think has been most poorly communicated
to the public by scientists when you say
yeah quantum computing I would say
I have to say in part I don't think we
would have done anyway cuz it's such a
complicated topic but part of why we
decided not to do it is the sense we got
talking to people in the field was that
they universally felt like pop science
media basically never gets it right and
the reason is so I don't know if any of
you I've read anything about quantum
computing but probably the impression
you have is something like it's like a
magic next type of computer that'll sort
of be faster somehow and so a couple
things on that one it has it's highly
suspected but it not has not yet been
proven to my understanding that you
could beat a classical computer at all
it's almost certainly the case pretty
much everyone we talked to said yes but
we don't know for sure that the math
shakes out
but in addition one quantum computers
only solve a narrow class of problems is
apparently bigger than we initially
thought there's a lot of cool stuff in
it but it's not like it's not just like
another computer that's faster it has to
be applied to narrow set of problems and
in addition all those problems involve a
step where you have like a supercomputer
so classical supercomputer coming in to
do stuff that the quantum computer so to
speak gives you kind of hints and it's
so a beautiful machine it's absolutely
wonderful but so maybe if you've read a
bit about it you've heard someone say
quantum computing can break RSA can
break the encryption algorithm that's
most common and that's probably true but
from what I understand like there's no
reason we couldn't switch off of RSA to
several other types of problem that a
quantum computer does not help with so
so the whole what everyone call crypto
military advantage of it is highly
questionable that's it I mean you know
the idea that on some level depending on
your interpretation you were like using
all of the multiverses to like get into
your ex's email that's pretty cool but
but but but yeah I highly encourage you
if you want to learn about quantum
computing there's a wonderful book by
Jonathan Dowling called Schrodinger's
killer app it's very it's very I know I
know yeah that book makes it sound like
it's more poppy than it is it's actually
a pretty thick book but nothing that you
couldn't understand with a little
patience
if you're a bit nerdy let's say if you
flirted with discrete math at any point
it's not too bad pretty high bummer
just just flirted how would
transplanting matter up cop and nanotube
actually work so you'd have a space
elevator that would connect to the
carbon nanotube and then it would sort
of just travel up the nanotube and in
order to get power to it you'd have to
beam it up so there have recently been X
Game that's called X game right X PRIZE
yeah there have been XPrize contests to
try to figure out how to beam power up
to the space elevator so that you can
keep it going as it grips on to the
carbon nanotube and carries itself up do
you have more to add to that I may just
like to because they're so far off don't
quite exist there are different ways you
might do it I think there's some
evidence you could you could you
actually use the cable to transmit power
up but it's tricky and you might like
naively say well we'll load some like
superconductors or copper on it but
remember those substances don't have the
specific strength to hang on the cable
so you're pretty limited in your options
beaming is probably the way to go but
but the way I'd like to say it I just
say this because sometimes you'll hear a
news item that's like big development on
space elevator the hardest problem
really is the middle part everything
else is like engineering the middle part
is the closest thing to magic so we
might not even have the right substance
yet so so any any news item you hear
that's not you know advanced in high
specific strength material is at least
questionable yeah I will do a couple
more questions your one up front
I'm curious how much of this was
reporting with people and how much of it
was painstakingly picking through
articles manuals and books
it was both I mean we read a painful
number of Springer and CRC books really
painful and then also lots of just
straight-up scientific articles and then
for every chapter I interviewed three or
four people in the field and then we
sent it out to at least those many
people for comments and then
additionally we tried to send it out
some extra people who we hadn't
interviewed just so they could
double-check it and if you're interested
in the whole process for how we wrote
the book tomorrow night at caveat which
is a bar we're gonna do a whole podcast
episode that's going to be recorded live
on the episodes or sorry on hat on the
methods we use to write this book but
anyway we read it's on we did a bunch of
interviews and then I went through and
checked every single sentence to make
sure we had a reference for every single
sentence because we forgot we were gonna
need to write a bibliography and when
our editor was like send over that
bibliography we were like okay give us a
week anyway but it was I'm glad she
asked for it because the book is better
because of it but but anyway that was a
bad way yeah the only thing I would add
just just to clarify too is like I think
95 percent of our source material was
primary in that it was either an
academic article or something from you
know a book of proceedings or from the
mouth of a researcher who's an expert in
the field and we didn't do like
celebrity researchers we tried to find
people from like investigating the field
whose name seemed to come up often then
we try to get in touch with them and so
pretty much entirely primary sources
which which hopefully shows not just in
the like depth of research but also in I
suspect even if you're interested in a
field we probably got something you
haven't heard about so hopefully that
was the goal
if it's filled with a mustache here
kilee favorite parasite and why oh man
so the one I discovered should we
mention your parasitologist
parasitologist
not just a creepy person so we
discovered a parasitoid which is a kind
of parasite that needs to kill a toast
in order to complete its life cycle and
it is a parasitoid that infects a wasp
that lives in tree branches so this wasp
makes a little compartment called a
crypt and it undergoes development there
and if it doesn't get infected and its
life is great it chews a little hole out
and flies away but when it gets infected
the parasitoid makes the wasp chew a
hole and then plug the hole with its
head and then it dies there while the
parasitoid eats its insides and so that
we call that the Cryptkeeper wasps and
we named it uterus set so uterus is the
genus that the parasitic I would spelled
her uterus is spelled EU de ru s which
is much less fun than the other one what
you might be thinking and so anyway the
genus was already determined after we
keyed this thing out so we didn't get to
pick that but we named it after the
Egyptian god set who trapped his brother
Osiris in a crypt and later scattered
his body parts and if you open up these
crypts you find scattered remains of the
wasp that it killed so anyway the Crypt
Keeper wasp is awesome thanks for that
question here I appreciate that there
were way too many SMBC questions yeah
I'm joking
woman back there so I'm a tech writer
and I was wondering if you guys ever got
frustrated when you were writing about
something and then a brand new
development came out and you had already
written about it how do you deal with
that we the answer would have been
drinking but we had
I was pregnant at the time for most of
this book but so for that the two main
problems we had were with SpaceX being
awesome and causing us to constantly
need to edit our cheap access to space
chapter but that was fine it was mostly
just like advances in their rockets and
then we had finished the chapter on
augmented reality and then Pokemon go
came out and so that required some
editing but it ended up being good in a
couple different ways so one now
everybody has a better sense of what
augmented reality augmented reality is
so it was a little easier to describe
and to in our concerned section we had
talked about how you know hypothetically
if you have this augmented world you
could get the augmented world
interacting with the real world in ways
that the real worlds didn't want it to
interact so like for example you could
have an augmented world where someone
drew a swastika on on a door on you know
on someone's door and how can you have
the right to ask them to get rid of that
you know what are the rules there and
Pokemon go ended up setting up poki
stops in the Holocaust Museum and at
Auschwitz and at the Hiroshima bomb
memorial and so we were able to say like
indeed the augmented reality world can
do things that the real world really
wishes weren't happening and I guess the
answer in that case is you're right
Nintendo and you say please stop being
jerks like squirtle shouldn't be you
know yeah at all shu 'it's please get
him out of there
and I think Nintendo complied and so it
did end up being a little bit more work
but in both of those cases that ended up
being useful just like you know added
that in it made it more interesting I
can I add they're our experts in
augmented reality said Pokemon doesn't
count okay and the essential reason is
Pokemon is not which we defined
augmented reality I'll have a general
sense of augmented reality of okay good
so you know the way you play pokemon you
should you should explain it go ahead
okay so augmented reality is like you
you will have some sort of device that
covers your vision and occlude certain
parts of the world giving you the
perception that virtual objects are
interfacing with reality so you can
imagine you could have one where you you
all saw like a little dragon hopping up
and down here so in Pokemon it would be
like the Pikachu or whatever would just
be kind of just floating generally over
here so it's geographically somewhere
but in an ideal augmented-reality
setting which would happen is Pikachu
should be sitting here and have a shadow
cast according to these lights and
should make a specific noise in your ear
when he walks across cloth instead of
say marble and in addition should have
some way of knowing quote-unquote that
there's like a book here so if he wants
to get past the book he has to hop over
it or something so what's that that's
called being in registration like the
virtual world is in registration with
reality and Pokemon doesn't quite do
that there's some there's some cool
games and things coming out to do but so
that there's a sort of academic
distinction that's made now that you're
done writing the book what are you
learning about or doing research on
these days what it's like to tour for a
party we have a bunch of research for my
like real job that I need to finish
before we start on the next project so
that's what I'm working on and then
you're working on a book with Brian
yeah I'm this is a couple years out I'm
working on a economist named Brian Kapil
and there's probably a couple turbo
dorks out there know Brian and it's well
you know I usually I'm really close to
the vest about what future projects are
about but Brian super enthusiastic and
has told everyone everything so so it's
a pro-immigration nonfiction graphic
novel with an economist so I'm learning
a bit about that and then I don't know
then that just my usual reading schedule
I'm really into an author named Neville
shoot anyone
Neville shoot yeah so that's all god I
that's what we're up to right now based
on your experience what would your
advice be to anyone who wants to combine
marriage with a massive collaborative
book project so actually when we first
started dating our favorite activity was
to go to a library and work all day and
then during our lunch breaks and at
night walk back and talk about what we
learned and so a major part of our
relationship like going through has just
been about talking about nerdy stuff
that we're learning at the time so it
just turned out for the last two years
all of those nerdy things were
technologies for soonish but then we
also have a nice our personalities are
different enough that division of labor
worked out well so I wanted to do all
the interviews he didn't so I did it I
have the personality that can go through
a book sentence by sentence and find the
bibliography that might have killed him
yes and and he's clearly like the
hilarious one who put the jokes in there
and he's got the artistic ability so he
drew the comics and then we just sort of
split up who was doing the reading of
like the CRC books in the primary
literature and we split up the book in
such a way that like one of us would
write a draft before the other one
started reading a lot of primary
literature and that was helpful because
that way you could figure out what you
weren't explaining clearly because the
other person didn't know about the
technology yet so I'm not sure if I
answered your question but that's how it
worked for us yeah I I just in terms of
collaborations I have two rules I always
advise ability is one of which is for
any given task someone's the leader it
doesn't matter who but someone needs to
be the one who feels responsibility for
failure so so we kind of what are you
smirking at me okay that's what we did
per chapters yeah yeah so per chapter or
even per like task in writing the book
one person essentially was in charge and
had like veto power over things got to
make choices about how it was done
when you don't do that when it's muddy
who's in charge people start to get mad
at each other because they always feel
like something and someone else's
responsibility or they're not getting to
do what they thought they were going to
do so make sure that's clear the second
thing is if something's irritating you
in a collaboration you're the jerk if
you don't speak up even if you feel like
the other person's a problem if you
don't speak up you're the problem
so it's really important to have someone
you can communicate with and which is
probably also a good marriage thing I
don't know we don't work to are the
marriage and yeah but I also kind of
having a thick skin helps because like
you know you spend a month researching
and writing a chapter and then you send
it to your partner and they're like ah
start over and you need to be like well
I'd really like this to be a good book
so I'll start over yeah you have to put
your ego second to a quality product
which is really cuz it's like no matter
what this one says like this chapter
stinks like it doesn't feel great to
hear that you dread
not hear that but if you have a good
working relationship you know the other
person is not trying to tear you down
you know so hand over here and then you
which one of you is the stronger reader
and which one of you is the better
writer I'm the best at both that's the
answer
hi so if all of those technologies could
actually come be completed within your
lifetime is there anything you would
actually be excited about that you
wouldn't actually use so I I think that
for all of these technologies we would
be in line for them but we'd be in like
the back twenty fifth percent of the
line like I think I'd like you know
brain computer interface I don't know
maybe I'd try one but I'd want to make
sure that it worked on the other 75% of
the people before me I don't want to be
the first one up on the space elevator
we're very we're very risk-averse we
really like researching these things
from the safety of our homes home we
have one home I mean I would say that
the two that would be that are hard to
say would be bad in any case or we do
one chapter on what's called precision
medicine which is kind of like a
molecular statistical approach to
medicine and the other is on bio
printing with a specific focus on organ
printing like printing a kidney or
praying a liver or even a printing a
cornea more basic stuff so you know we
sometimes good-ass like like are there
anything you just don't want to happen
or that you do and those are the two
that there really aren't aren't a lot of
serious ethical issues with with
improving medicine or ability to give
people organs I mean there are some
things that are worth thinking about but
there we felt they were pretty clearly
outweighed by the by the positives I
agree with you on bioprinting you don't
want you don't want people to have good
medicine is that what you're saying yeah
I hate people yeah yeah well so you know
for precision medicine we talked about
like using CRISPR to edit people's
genomes to solve problems
and there's I think there's a lot of
discussion that still needs to happen
about whether or not that's okay and
what cells are okay to edit and which
ones aren't so I think precision
medicine still has some things that yeah
and the false positive thing like if
it's a precision medicine means every
time you go to the doctor maybe you get
ten thousand tiny little tests for on
you and if they're wrong or give a false
positive one time in a thousand that
means every time you go to the doctor
you find out you have ten things that
you don't actually have so there's like
it sort of sounds kind of boring but
there's a deep statistical problem with
some of these methods that's fascinating
fascinating I mean okay one more
question in the back in the back you
could talk to us afterwards you have to
answer any questions yes um you both
talked a lot about how much work you put
into this book and thank you for that
but uh I was wondering was there ever a
topic that you came away from and just
thought man I never want to read
anything about that again and if it was
quantum computing just say was something
else I I actually so I was only doing
the research on quantum computing and I
actually it was such a delightful field
I would I would have loved to stayed
there I had to go on to other stuff
there's one chapter that's actually not
mentioned in the book that got cut very
late so we actually are the manuscript
we turned in had eleven chapters and the
the eleventh was advanced nuclear
fission reactors so just in case you
don't know the type of reactor we have
right now but with advanced features and
I was pretty sick of that by the end and
yeah I think was a very good chapter in
some ways it was one of the best cuz it
was just like there's this thing that's
very important to all our lives that
most people don't know how it works and
furthermore actually nuclear reactors of
very from an aerial view is a very
simple machine it's a I would say it's
easier to explain than a combustion
engine it's quite simple so it was fun
but it was very ticky tacky in terms of
details and and the main reason I think
is because it's a technology that's been
around since in some form or another
since the 40s so a lot of the stuff so
naively when we said to ourselves we're
gonna research advanced nuclear reactors
there's the thing called generation for
nuclear reactors it sounds like it's
gonna be really Spacey and weird most of
the changes have to do with like passive
safety features
different cladding for fuel and you know
so it's like as nerds it's super
interesting but it's like you know going
into a detailed discussion of why you
might want like helium as a moderator
instead of you know deuterated water is
just not for everyone perhaps and and so
furthermore for us like you know we talk
about space elevator you're really
talking pretty abstractly you're talking
about like physical quantities and in
the shape of things so like that makes
it way easier to research because you
know you read about nuclear stuff and
there's all these just tiny variations
and all sorts of different things and
and your mind starts to wobble with the
complexity of it all so we were pretty
pretty well sick of that but a totally
interesting field wonderful people we
felt bad having to cut it really
important research yeah really important
but but it was it was tough that was a
very there were a lot of really thick
technical books we had to go through for
that one yeah we mentioned that it's
your birthday
thank you no no you don't have to sing
but thank you but that's nice of you to
ask okay thank you that's it Thank You
Zack and Kelly you've been such a great
audience it's been so much fun and
learned so much so you're gonna stick
around and sign copies for us Thanks so
we're gonna move on to the signing now
if we could have the first two rows just
kind of line up in this sorry got too
close to the speaker there if we could
have the first two rows sign up in the
line light up in that aisle we do have
more books for sale and they're back
register with Paul if you are interested
and past that thank you very much for
coming have a great night
[Music]
here's a look at some books being
published this week former Vice
President Joe Biden reflects on how he
balanced his professional duties and
tended to his ailing son in promise me
dad
in Bannon White House reporter Keith
Koffler explores the life of Steve
Bannon and his future in American
politics Kevin Young director of the New
York Public Library Schomburg Center
provides a history of forgeries and
falsehoods in the United States from PT
Barnum to fake news in the National Book
Award nominated bunk also being
published this week presidential
historian mark Updegrove looks at the
relationship and political careers of
presidents George HW Bush and George W
Bush in the last Republicans the Vanity
Fair Diaries shares the experiences of
Tina Brown during her time as
editor-in-chief of the publication Helen
Thorp reports on 22 refugee teenagers at
a Denver High School in the newcomers
and in the friendly orange glow tech
entrepreneur Brian deer explores the
creation and legacy of the Plato
programming system a precursor to
today's online communities look for
these titles in bookstores this coming
week and watch for many of the authors
in the near future on book TV on c-span
too
tonight on afterwards it was imperative
for me because I had a platform and that
this is my 15 minutes then Here I am and
if I I'm here today I'm not speaking on
behalf of the FBI am i speaking on
behalf of any Intelligence Agency and
I'm not